bloodborne has one of the best stories i
have ever seen it's widely regarded
amongst fans as a masterpiece and one of
the best in the souls series and after
finishing the game myself i'm inclined
to agree welcome back to another story
review the series where we look at some
old games and i not only give you a
retelling of the game's story but also
give my opinions along the way we've
already done a few of these in the past
and i plan to do many more in the future
so if this interests you in any way
consider watching some of my previous
episodes or subscribe for future ones
but as for today we'll just be focusing
on bloodborne so without further ado
let's get started as always i want to
put a massive spoiler warning now as
we'll be going through the entire game
and dlc throughout this video although i
do understand though that many may not
even know what bloodborne is so allow me
to give you a very basic spoiler-free
rundown of the game's plot then you can
decide from there bloodborne takes place
in a fictional world of yharnam and we
play as someone only known as the hunter
yharnam is known across the world for
its blood administration as the blood
they use is said to cure all illnesses
we're an outsider who came to yharnam to
seek this blood in hopes of possibly
healing us but that's not all this blood
does the blood in yharnam has a secret a
secret the healing church does not want
getting out furthermore that's not the
only secret yharnam has within its walls
sadly this is all i can say for now
without ruining most of the story if
this sounds remotely interesting to you
then go buy the game sadly though it is
only on playstation so i can understand
if you can't get your hands on it now
that the introduction is out of the way
let's actually dive into the game's
narrative so right away bloodborne
foregoes the usual lengthy cutscene that
gives a summary of the world's events
originally i was going to write a
strongly worded paragraph on how much
this annoyed me but after looking at it
differently i realized how much of this
story would genuinely be ruined with an
introduction like the previous games the
reason being is that bloodborne is
hiding its actual story for most of the
game and if any of the history or events
of the world were mentioned then it
would not only make the player more
confused it would also ruin the surprise
so instead the first second of the game
starts with someone walking up to us
talking about yharnam and something
called pale blood it's assumed that our
character had asked a question to the
blood minister and that the cutscene
starts right after we ask it so it's
possible that our character was trying
to seek this pale blood but given that
they're trying to get a blood
transfusion it's possible that the
players also afflicted with some illness
and sought out yharnam because of their
extraordinary blood however before we're
given the blood we need to sign a
contract because the blood of yharnam is
so sought after by the rest of the world
it's obviously in high demand so as
payment the church requires a contract
to be signed but this contract isn't so
that we pay them for their services but
rather be of service to the people of
yharnam as thanks for being given their
blood in yharnam a strange phenomenon
has occurred as we can see that the town
is overrun by beasts by signing the
contract we become a hunter and our task
of bringing an end to the hunt so it can
be surmised that this hunt we partake in
is our end goal except that's not
entirely true it's clear we the player
didn't come to yharnam to stop the hunt
we came here for the blood our actual
objective is much different however
there is a slight problem right after
receiving the blood we wake up and the
first thing we see is a note that reads
seek the pale blood and transcend the
hunt this note highlights an issue with
bloodborne's writing which are the
translations the first half of this note
is incorrect from software the creators
of the game are known to be japanese so
translation errors are quite frequent in
their games this can sometimes be a few
incorrect words or the whole description
missing at least within the english
version some of the text is wrong this
note doesn't actually say handwritten
scrawl as in japanese it actually says
scribbled in your own handwriting
implying that our character wrote this
note but in the english version that's
not explained which is why there are
constant questions on many forms as to
who wrote the note despite there being a
clear answer this isn't the only
translation error that bloodborne has
but it's definitely the most notable
after the note is read we head
downstairs to fight the very first enemy
and we die this however teleports us to
the hunter's dream the reason we're here
is that earlier before getting up from
the table we hear the blood minister say
that we will simply be seeing a bad
dream before a beastly figure appears in
front of us is engulfed in flames right
after these tiny little white men which
we learn are called messengers surround
our body these little guys worship and
aid the hunters in the hunter's dream
and it's because they're connected to
the player that allows us passage into
that hunter's dream the place's name is
a bit misleading as it's a real place
but it's not a real place like it
doesn't exist within yharnam physically
but it's also not a dream because we can
physically die in here this may sound
extremely confusing but i do have a
theory on this that i'll explain a bit
later when we get to the nightmare
realms getting back on track we discover
that we aren't alone in this stream as
there is a doll that becomes our level
up lady and then there's german the
first hunter the hunter's dream becomes
a base of operations for the player but
was also a base of operations for many
other hunters that came before us as not
only are there graves everywhere
signifying that people used to be here
the doll also just straight up tells us
this while we're in here we finally get
to pick our weapons and finish our
loadout bloodborne handles combat much
differently than the other souls games
and while it may not be intentional i
think this flows quite well with the
game's story firstly all the hunters
carry a weapon and a gun at all times
however there isn't much to choose from
in this game just as a quick comparison
not including the guns there are only 26
melee weapons the player can use
compared to dark souls 1 where 26
weapons just fills up the straight
swords and greatswords there's still a
dozen other categories of weapons that
haven't even been mentioned furthermore
the game has also removed armor and
changed it to a tire out of all the
clothing in the game i think there's one
armor set that actually says the word
armor on the item as opposed to robe or
garb so bloodborne has significantly
decreased the quantity of both
categories but you know that saying
quality over quantity and i think
bloodborne ran with this idea in terms
of the way i see it as a hunter
especially when it comes to hunting
beasts such as these mastery of your
weapon is not only expected of you but
it's required if you want to stay alive
so by giving the player fewer weapons it
gives them fewer options and possibly
more time with one weapon one of the
first weapons available to the player is
the flagship saw cleaver i used this
weapon the entire game this is because
bloodborne's weapons are all about the
moveset rather than the damage the worst
weapon based on damage is the blade of
mercy at 60 with the highest being 105
which belongs to the kirkhammer compared
to other games where starting damage can
be anywhere from 55 to 160 depending on
the weapon it makes this game's damage
difference irrelevant what i'm trying to
convey is that the game is almost
encouraging you to be a real hunter by
dedicating a long time to one weapon now
of course you're free to change to
whatever weapon you want whenever you
want as it's quite generous with upgrade
materials but i've always felt this lack
of quantity was intentional so that the
player feels like a proper hunter one
who has dedicated time to mastering the
inner workings of the weapon this is
further reinforced by the game's trick
system which changes the weapon's form
and not only adds more moves to the
weapon but also different combo strings
as you can switch forms mid combination
as for the attire on the surface this
may not make sense but given how the
flow of combat works i think it fits
perfectly within this game in bloodborne
dodge rolls only exist when not locked
on as when in combat your character does
a dash on top of this their health loss
isn't permanent as the rally mechanic
allows you to regain health back by
attacking the enemy the rally and dash
mechanic try to push the player towards
a more aggressive style of play
especially when you take into account
the visceral attacks and how some runes
can give your health back from them the
game is trying to push you to use your
healing items as a last resort and this
quick pace of combat would be impossible
if the player was covered in armor so
bloodborne removed armor and added a
tire since it's a lot lighter and gives
the player more freedom of movement by
far my favorite things to look into is
how the gameplay ties into the story and
bloodborne does a fantastic job at this
by giving meaning to the weapons and
armor we find in game as while may seem
trivial many games don't even bother
really putting in that effort to justify
these things so when it does occur in
cases like bloodborne it allows me to be
more invested in the story as everything
was taken into account after selecting
our equipment we can head back and kill
the beast that defeated us once it's
defeated we can walk outside the clinic
and enter central yharnam and i gotta
say bloodborne is stunning not just in
the actual design of yharnam but the
small details put into the levels as
well yharnam clearly takes inspiration
from the victorian era but adds a more
gothic twist to it as evidenced by the
rough and lethal architecture like the
overuse of spikes near letters and the
overall neutral color palette the town
has one thing that has irked me on
occasion is most of the souls games take
place in a broken land that is way past
its prime but not a single game has ever
actually convinced me that this is the
case until i played bloodborne some
standout levels though like undead burg
and fair and keep do do an excellent job
at conveying this the inbuilt bloodborne
carries this throughout the entire game
there is so much death and decay within
these areas that you can feel how
miserable the people are here but that's
just on the surface as there are those
smaller details i talked about where
within a few minutes after leaving the
clinic you can find a large crowd of the
townspeople huddled around a fire pit
the town's people are also called the
yarnamites so i'll be using that from
now on this may not seem significant
until you realize that in the fire pit
is a cross with a beast being crucified
on it this one tiny area shows the
disdain people have for these beasts and
shows that the hunters aren't the only
ones fighting back against the beast's
curse but once again this also makes
sense as hunters are trained to fight
these creatures which is why you
normally find them alone whereas the
jarnamites are just regular people so
they travel in packs which is why we
fight large numbers of them these small
details continue to get even smaller as
certain characters like the old hunters
from the dlc have belts around their
right leg if you notice while playing
our player heals by stabbing something
into their right leg the old hunter
trouser reads a widespread belief of the
period was that beast blood crept up the
right leg and this led to the double
wrapped belt these design decisions and
small details are just like the weapons
and attire we previously talked about
details that didn't need much backstory
as the player probably wouldn't have
noticed or cared if it wasn't added but
by adding them it shows that not only
are from software genuinely good
developers but every detail was taken
into consideration getting back on track
our objective is still to seek the pale
blood and transcend the hunt however
this is quite obscure and vague so
thankfully bloodborne provides a much
more approachable and straightforward
objective from a note in the hunter's
dream that reads to escape this dreadful
hunter's dream halt the source of the
spreading scourge of beasts less than
i'd carry on forever even if the
previous objective makes zero sense this
at least gives us something to think
about and also acts as a justification
for our actions except there is a slight
issue as not only do the beasts attack
us but the yarnamites do as well this is
bizarre as i just talked about how the
yharnamites are taking part in the hunt
alongside us but this is cleared up by
the story it's discovered that the cause
of the beast is from the blood itself
currently we don't know why it's the
blood or what is in the blood that's
causing this problem we just know that
this is the reason why this is very
typical of souls games where questions
will be answered with a brief summary
that gets more complex and fleshed out
as we continue for now though what we
uncover is that the blood of yharnam is
more intoxicating than alcohol and this
addiction to blood is what's causing
people to seek out more and since it
already has some disastrous side effects
the more someone consumes the worse
it'll get this may not be the same for
all the residents but if you pay
attention to the blood-borne trailer
when the camera zooms in on the eye of
the yarn might you can see that their
pupil is sort of broken or misshapen and
it also looks eerily similar to the eye
of a blood drunk hunter the item we used
to enter the dlc and just like the item
says even hunters aren't safe from this
inevitable fate in fact i think they're
worse off than many as they're
constantly killing beasts and surrounded
by the hunt that's why characters like
eileen the crow exist as when you meet
her she tells us that while we're a
hunter of beasts she's a hunter of
hunters throughout her questline we
assist her in killing certain hunters
who may have been consumed with blood
bust it's her duty as the hunter of
hunters to grant them a merciful death
however even she is not immune to this
fate as if we don't do her quest line
instead of the crow of cainhurst
arriving at the cathedral she'll be here
and attack us instead implying that she
too succumbed to the bloodlust and it
was because of us assisting her in her
hunts that we were able to prevent this
fate from happening however just as the
hunters within bloodborne are unique so
too are the beasts the first two bosses
of bloodborne are actually a really
great visualization of the facts the
blood has on people as we can find the
cleric beast a beast we definitely
haven't seen before and father gascoigne
a hunter drunk from bloodlust but it's
also here where bloodborne deviates from
the other games in regards to its
storytelling bloodborne focuses more on
context clues for its lore rather than
item descriptions the descriptions do
exist but definitely play less of a role
in bloodborne compared to the other
souls games where one boss will have a
soul weapons and possibly armor tied to
it giving you seven different pieces of
information in bloodborne most of the
time you'll just get one and even then
you're lucky to get that for example the
cleric piece drops one item called the
sword hunter's badge where the last
sentence reads as it was clerics
transformed into the most hideous beasts
from this item we can conclude that the
clerics who were a part of the healing
church the organization that distributes
the blood were affected by the blood
even more than the yarnamites or
possibly the hunters due to them being
near it all day this caused them to
transform into different forms of beasts
which are much different than the ones
we find in yharnam even without this
item you probably could have came up
with this idea as the boss's name is
cleric beast implying that it's a beast
that used to be a cleric this is the
same for father gascoigne who only drops
a key to the door behind him we don't
get any lore from him on why he turned
into a beast but given our knowledge on
the blood of yharnam and the beast curse
we can come to the assumption that he
was consumed by bloodlust these are much
more tame examples but it becomes
tougher when you talk about bosses like
the one reborn which drop absolutely
nothing regarding its backstory but
because the area it's located in and the
area's history we can use small bits of
lore to piece together our own story
about the boss this will inevitably
frustrate players as the most basic form
of lore that being the boss souls and
items are no longer a viable way to
understand the story but personally i
don't mind the way bloodborne altered
its own way of storytelling it's
definitely more difficult than other
souls games and especially when we get
deeper into the game but it was a nice
change of pace and it forced me to think
about my surroundings and actively pay
attention as i said i didn't mind this
but i can see many people who will be
annoyed or even turned off by this as
the game provides even less ways to
access key items after defeating father
gescoin we're able to enter the odin
chapel and subsequently the cathedral
ward and a tier where the game becomes a
bit more open and that's where i believe
the tutorial officially ends the
cathedral award will act as our
temporary base of operations but only in
the sense that we're going to be coming
back here quite often from here the
player can explore many different areas
like hemwick old yharnam and the
forbidden woods however before going to
these areas we need to clear out the
cathedral ward itself to prevent some
backtracking because at the end of this
level is vicar emilia similar to father
gascoigne she doesn't drop much except
dependent which just tells us that
vickers were heads of the healing church
and this pendant they carry is to remind
them of their old adage which is fear
the old blood but once again you didn't
need this info as her story is just like
the cleric beast someone who transformed
into a different beast thanks to the
high amounts of blood that were around
them the reason we have to defeat her so
that we can touch the skull behind her
which shows a cut scene of two people
talking to one another that being master
willem and lawrence these two will play
a massive role later afterwards we can
visit oldie arnhem and this highlights
another wonderful detail about
bloodborne and that's not only do the
characters and bosses have great stories
but the areas do as well and it's these
locations that assist us in providing
backstories to those characters and
bosses within the area such as in old
yharnam where upon entering we're told
to leave should we refuse we get shot at
by someone atop a tower we discovered
that this person is a hunter named
dejira this is the first instance we see
of hunters defending the beast from
other hunters which is quite odd given
their whole job is to kill them but
oliver arnhem has quite the tragic
backstory old yharnam and its residents
were ravaged by a sickness known as
ashen blood and due to its poisonous
effects it caused more of the beast
scourge to spread and because it was
spreading too fast drastic measures
needed to be taken so oliviarno was
locked away and burned to the ground
this relates to why dejura is protecting
them because he feels guilty for what
happened and assuming you don't anger
him like i did you can talk to him
peacefully and when spoken to he'll say
this
i no longer dream but i was once a
hunter too
there's nothing more horrific than a
hunt
in case you fail to realize
the things you hunt
they're not beasts
they're people
one day you will see
i really like the addition of dejorah as
a character because it humanizes things
in yharnam as it shows that there are
hunters out there who genuinely care
about what they're hunting and feel
terrible about it he realized that the
beasts he was trying to kill are just
regular people and even though they're
beasts he can't use that as
justification to kill them especially
when you take into account how the
people of oldian were even turned into
beasts in the first place that's why de
jure doesn't blame the beast but rather
the church as they were inflicted with a
disease that was accelerated thanks to
the church and it was the church
themselves that deemed the place
unlivable which is why it was sectioned
off and burned it's a horrific but
wonderfully crafted story and a lot of
the locations in bloodborne do have
incredible backstories that really make
you stop and think once you get all the
details for example after going through
a few other areas we'll eventually make
it to bergenworth and it's here where
the story of bloodborne reaches its
climax birgenworth is a place of study
here in yharnam as we make our way
through the building we can come across
a man on a chair who will know to be
master willem thanks to the flashback
from earlier master willem is the head
of the bergenworth scholars here in
yharnam and they made a very disastrous
discovery we don't know what that
discovery is but we'll find out shortly
as while willem can't speak to us he
does motion us towards the ledge and by
jumping into the water we enter another
plane of existence with the only thing
in here being rom the evacus spider
killing rom is the start of the mystery
after her death we see a lady who we
will eventually discover to be the
undead thumerian queen who's also named
yharnam after we speak with her the moon
glows a violent red color as it inches
closer and closer to us in fact so close
that the clouds are actually traveling
behind it thankfully though we awake
from the terrifying nightmare and are
back on the mainland at least you can go
on believing that as long as you don't
look up this creature is an amygdala and
it's not only a species of creatures
that have existed in yharnam it's also
been here the whole time we've been
playing you can visit this exact area
before reaching rom and assuming you're
careless enough to not look around
something invisible will grab you and
give you a sneak peek of the real story
of yharnam but this alien creature is
just the tip of the iceberg because
bloodborne was never actually about the
hunt it's about ascension and
experimentation and most importantly of
all it's about the great ones this is
where the story of bloodborne
permanently changes and to help you get
up to speed let me explain what's
exactly going on here and don't worry if
you get lost or confused along the way
i'll try to summarize the basic details
at the end bloodborne's story begins
years ago when an ancient race of people
called thumerians would discover the
great ones and thus lead to their wisdom
of the eldritch truth the eldritch truth
is basically a catch-all phrase for the
great ones esthemarians were able to
discover that the great ones exist and
that they inhabit a higher plane of
existence much higher than our own all
of this pretty much encompasses the
eldritch truth eventually the thumerians
would become the eternal guardians of
the great ones which is why they're
present in the chalice dungeons we enter
from the hunter's dream as those are the
places they rested after some time all
the great ones ascended to an even
higher plane of existence except ebridis
who was the only one left behind a bit
farther in the future the pthumerians
would establish a government system and
elect a monarch who we know to be queen
yharnam she ended up having a child who
was named mergo but mergo was special as
it was a half human but half great one
hybrid multiple lore descriptions tell
us that the great ones will inevitably
lose their children so they seek out
surrogates at this point in time queen
yharnam would be the surrogate but other
characters will also be affected like
aryana and yosefka as killing them drops
an umbilical cord years go by and we
reach the establishment of the
bergamorth college this was led by
master willem the scholars of the
college would eventually discover those
areas we discussed before that we know
as chalice dungeons and would uncover
the history of the thumerians as well as
the existence of what they call the old
blood this old blood is the blood of the
great ones and this was the turning
point for both byrgenwerth and yharnam
as all their time was dedicated to
figuring out how to not only communicate
with these beings but also ascend to
their level of existence this led to the
scholars testing the old blood but while
overseeing the tests of the old blood
master willem feared its effects as they
were still unknown which is why he says
the phrase fear the old blood that
cutscene we saw earlier is when lawrence
would leave the college lawrence
believed that the blood was the key to
humanity's ascension as this blood had
incredible healing properties master
willem however still believed that
ascending was only possible by lining
the brain with eyes allowing the
individual to gain insight into the
great ones this is further reinforced by
the creatures we kill in byrgenwerth who
have multiple eyes because they're
falling out many of the scholars in the
college were forced to choose who to
side with after the split occurred
between master willem and lawrence
master willem would continue his
research while lawrence and the members
who followed created the healing church
due to having a proper setup and a base
of operations the method of blood
transfusion was quickly discovered but
as we know this made things worse in
yharnam as it created the beast courage
so lawrence worked with german to create
the first hunter's workshop so they
could stop the beasts clearly that
didn't work and the other organizations
and then the healing church would start
to take notice these groups being the
choir and the school of mensis just like
the prior groups the choir and the
school of menses also wanted to ascend
to a higher plane of existence but their
creation was made shortly after the
downfall of the healing church as not
only was it proven that the blood was
not working as they wanted it to
lawrence would also pass away leaving
the spot for leader up for grabs so with
the church in ruins and its leader dead
the rest of its members started taking
matters into their own hands the choir
had the advantage of being able to visit
ibritis the left behind great ones so
they tried using her as well as other
experiments and involving children in
their newly built orphanage they would
use these kids and turn them into
celestial emissaries with the intention
of either being great ones themselves or
using these emissaries as a way to
communicate with the great ones so that
they could learn more on them the choir
clothing set says together with the left
behind great one they look to the skies
in search of astral signs as that may
lead them to the discovery of their true
greatness they were also able to use
what we would call magic as the auger of
a british was quite common amongst their
ranks as for the school of mensis they
were led by a mikalash who also happens
to use the same auger of a british magic
which may imply that the school of
mensis were originally members of the
choir or at the very least miklash at
least used to be they're responsible for
creating a ritual called the mensis
ritual which is an extremely confusing
piece of lore that is never actually
really explained some have said that it
has to do with the snatchers kidnapping
people and using those people in their
rituals but there's also information
that points to michaelash using a child
possibly murgo to lure the red moon to
them mensis may be a reference to the
word month when talking about the moon
and its monthly phases so it seems like
the moon was a part of their goal but to
what end though is unclear regardless
they performed the menses ritual and
were able to create the nightmare of
mensis a nightmare realm i will get to
later within this realm though are queen
yharnam and her son mergo which is quite
peculiar basically though all of these
groups separated due to their differing
ideals and would even sabotage each
other at times as we can summon a
immense student to fight abridus who of
course we know is to be affiliated with
the choir and to even get into the
choir's orphanage we need to find a key
to the upper cathedral ward which is
located on a corpse in a cage which is
in yahara ghoul run by the school of
menses while this division in the church
was occurring one rogue scholar would
reach out to castle cainhurst a place
that had already existed for quite some
time and would then travel there to
share their blood discoveries with them
the healing church would catch wind of
this betrayal and spin a story that
basically caused a holy crusade as they
claimed that castle cainhurst were
creating vile beasts and needed to be
stopped this led to the creation of a
group of hunters called the executioners
who assaulted the castle the only
problem is that the queen of the castle
and elise is immortal to my knowledge
this is never explained but has been the
basis of many theories this immortality
caused a problem because they couldn't
kill the source of the vile bloods which
is why legarius leader of the
executioners can be seen in front of the
throne room as he locked her away
permanently and guards the room so that
no one may enter to free her this also
leads into alfred's questline who is
also an executioner and is way more than
delighted to see the queen there
you filthy monstrosity
what good's your immortality now
try stirring up trouble in this sorry
state
all mangled and twisted with every
inside on the outside for all the world
to see
[Laughter]
so quickly let me summarize what i just
said so basically bergenworth found the
tombs we known as chalice dungeons which
led to the discovery of the great ones
and the old blood the goal from then was
how to ascend to a higher plane of
existence the methods of ascension are
what created the different groups
birgenworth one by master willem
believed lining one's brain with eyes
would give the person insight this is
once again reinforced by the multi-guide
creatures at byrgenwerth lawrence
founder of the healing church believed
the old blood was the key to ascension
within this church were two groups of
hunters the official hunters led by
german who were created to stop the
beast curse from spreading and then the
executioners who were created to put
down the people of castle cainhurst as
they believed they were evil the last
two groups were the former members of
the church the choir wanted to use a
british and their creation of the
celestial emissaries is a mean of
ascension although once again it is
still unclear whether the members of the
choir wanted to become celestial
emersors or we're just using them as a
communication device to communicate with
the great ones and then finally was the
school of mensis who kidnapped people
and used them in obscene rituals and
were somehow able to create the
nightmare realm of mensis that contains
queen yharnam and her hybrid son mergo
this is just a small part of
bloodborne's story not only is there so
much we haven't discovered yet but there
are some details i left out of the
previous topics for the sake of brevity
and organization there is genuinely so
much to talk about and if this didn't
get you excited about the game's story
then i don't know what will because this
fundamentally changes how we see this
game i do want to clarify you don't
learn all this info i just explained
after killing rom the only reason i
waited until her death to explain the
full story is because the proper context
was needed as now we can reanalyze our
current knowledge and connect it to this
new discovery like rom herself who seems
to be just a spider until you realize
that rom was originally a scholar at
byrgenwerth who evolved into a great one
courtesy of coss or even how many of the
hunters and notable figures in the game
were blindfolds this could be based on a
theory within the game's world that the
scourge beast play causes people to lose
their eyesight but could also be a way
for the person to prevent going mad from
seeing the great ones which also
connects into the insight mechanic these
ideas could be completely wrong but
that's the point of creating a theory
and being able to connect new lore with
previous lore so seamlessly is fantastic
and a testament to how detailed the
world building of bloodborne really is
but like i said before we're not even
done with the game's story as there is
so much more to uncover but now we're
starting to enter questionable territory
if there was ever one massive fault in
bloodborne story it's the lack of
elaboration or just even a simple
explanation related to some of the
events and locations in the game we
briefly mentioned this before with some
of the bosses like the one reborn who
don't have a concrete backstory but
thanks to the history of yahar ghoul
were able to come up with a compelling
theory based on this information this
however is not the same when discussing
the nightmare realms bloodborne has this
fascination with dreams and nightmares
as across the game will end up visiting
four locations called the hunter's dream
hunter's nightmare nightmare frontier
and the nightmare of menses just about
all of them minus the hunter's nightmare
to an extent are extremely confusing and
very difficult to wrap your brain around
once again we're gonna have to rely on
context clues in the environment to help
us come up with a theory but there's
even less to go off of within these
realms as they're completely separate
from reality each of these places has a
host and its location is unknown but
it's assumed to be in a different plane
of existence but the location of this
new plane is possibly closer than we
think as we can see the cathedral ward
underneath the fishing hamlet and the
hunter's nightmare as well as being able
to see the nightmare of menses from the
nightmare frontier it's extremely
confusing as it seems that these places
could operate like yahar ghul and are
just simply an unseen village or do
exist but are unable to be preserved by
normal humans or maybe it's something
else entirely one thing that is for
certain is that there is a host that
created this specific realm for a
specific reason however for some of them
we still don't know why this is great as
it gets the community talking but theory
crafting is only useful when there's a
set amount of facts from which to build
off of but when it comes to these realms
there's very little to even start with
many have pointed out how these realms
are very similar to hp lovecraft's
dreamlands which in case you weren't
aware hp lovecraft was a massive
inspiration for this game according to
some of my research in this topic the
dreamlands are alternate dimensions only
accessible to humans through dreams
there's also a mention of the waking
world which is just the present realm
the characters are in so relating this
to bloodborne current day yharnam would
be our waking world and all these other
realms we visit are just the dreamlands
but once again the question still
remains how did these realms even come
to be well to start we have to talk
about the nightmare of menses to access
this realm we have to touch mikalash who
is clearly dead amongst the other
members of the group this nightmare
seemed to take in things from the real
world and put them in the nightmare not
completely removing them from yharnam
but more like duplicating them as the
lecture building seemed to belong in
yharnam originally after exiting the
lecture building we can officially make
it to the nightmare and it's clear this
group does not want to be disturbed as
protecting the gates is this beam of
light which comes from the brain of
menses the nightmare mensis is
interesting because it tries to convey
to the player how time works although
admittedly it does that quite poorly
another example of this is the chalice
dungeons these dungeons are extremely
unique as you can fight bosses like ram
inside of them this is very confusing
already but to add even more confusion
to the mix in the boss fight arena for
ebridis called the altar of despair it
looks like a british is bent over crying
when looking in the direction of what
seems to be rom's corpse so we have a
dead rom in the altar of despair and two
live roms one in the chalice dungeon and
one underneath the great lake at
byrgenwerth the only explanation that
i've come to is that it's related to
time and the ability to be in multiple
places at one time while i have no way
to explain the chalice dungeons other
than these places being a time in
history that has been frozen as for the
other two parts of rom the one in the
altar of despair seems to be the real
rom and the one of the lake is also the
real rom but not physically just like
how michelesh is dead in yahar ghoul but
very much alive in the nightmare it
seems that these realms work very
differently when it comes to time as
well as the physical body it's also even
more confusing when you consider that
there are different hosts per realm and
the ways of entry are different per
realm michelash more than likely can't
enter the hunter's dream as he's not a
hunter we can't enter the hunter's
nightmare without the eye of the blood
drunk hunter item as we'll see when we
discuss the dlc the hunter's nightmare
is for hunters who become drunk with
blood bust so if you don't fit the
criteria you can't enter which is why we
need the item to gain entry to it so how
does rom fit with all of this well many
within the community believe that all
these planes of existences are on layers
if we use yharnam as layer 1 then this
place where rom exists is layer 0. we
eventually discover that we can see the
cathedral from the hunter's nightmare
making that above it at layer 2. there's
even a possible theory that the amygdala
in the hunter's nightmare fell from the
nightmare frontier since it's the boss
of that area making that place layer
three continuing further many may
speculate that the nightmare frontier is
connected to the nightmare of menses due
to its close proximity and the fact that
the lecture building connects the two
places making the nightmare of mensis
just either the top layer of layer 3 or
maybe even its own at number 4. as for
the hunter's dream i believe it to be
the highest layer within the realms that
we know of as the ending of the game
kind of backs this up a bit i really do
like this theory a lot although it's
simply just a theory and it's impossible
to know if this is truly correct but
it's clear that the things in these
realms are not on the same system as
yharnam circling back to the nightmare
of mensis we know that mikalash is the
host of the nightmare evident by his
name so killing him would stop the
nightmare except that doesn't happen to
once again relate this to the hunter's
nightmare the only way to stop that
nightmare is to kill kos because that is
the host the orphan of course is not the
host as the nightmare doesn't end until
you kill the black spirit lingering
above coss itself but with the nightmare
of mensis it doesn't stop when you kill
mikalash as there is still another boss
left that being mergo's wet nurse the
wet nurse is protecting mergo and it's
only by killing myrgo that things
actually end technically you can revisit
these realms even though the host is
dead so i just chalked it up to game
design as technically within lore they
should be gone so it seems that these
realms operate differently depending on
its inhabitants both of the realms
officially end when the great one in
their respective realms is killed so
it's possible that the great ones hold
more power in these realms despite not
being the host in the case of mergo
although to be fair the nightmare of
menses was made so that mikelesh and the
students of menses could communicate
with mergo so maybe there's a loophole
there this is what i meant earlier when
i talked about bloodborne's biggest
issue because these past couple of
minutes have just been complete
speculation this whole theory has no
amount of truth to it since it's simply
just a theory there is nothing wrong
with leaving things up to interpretation
and allowing the community to answer the
mystery on their own but i feel like
there was something really lacking here
when it came to these realms it is
probably one of my favorite pieces of
lore to look into though as there is so
many diverse ideas but there's also an
issue because due to this lack of
explanation the community can't really
agree on anything concrete is a base
thus you have many outlandish ideas like
people thinking the realms or different
planets or yharnam is actually a realm
in itself and the real yharnam is
something we don't get to see or who
knows maybe my theory is completely
outlandish and those are more centered
in facts it's all over the place despite
the obvious issue the idea of these
realms and how they are planes that
exist that you aren't able to see by
normal means is such a cool concept and
further solidifies my previous statement
that bloodborne's world building is
insanely detailed and even something
like the nightmare realms are able to be
discussed thoroughly because the idea of
what these places are and what they
actually mean intrigues enough people to
want to uncover the real truth these
realms could have simply been boring
ideas in places that the players could
deem unworthy to even bother mentioning
but it's due to the writing of the rest
of the game that makes the very idea of
trying to uncover the full story even
including the nightmare realms almost
mesmerizing at this point in the game
the only boss that stands in our way is
mergo's wet nurse but killing the nurse
leads to the game's ending so before we
get into that ending we have to discuss
the dlc bloodborne only came with one
dlc called the old hunters this dlc
takes place in the hunter's nightmare
which as we discussed is a nightmare
realm created by a specific host for a
specific reason the purpose of this
place is to give the hunters who succumb
to bloodlust the place to go which
sounds rather wholesome until you
discover why the hunter's nightmare was
created pretty early in bloodborne's
timeline in the order of events we
previously discussed we have that era
where the college was founded and then
the old blood was found along with the
thumerian tombs and then afterwards the
college would then split up because of
all the different ideologies leading to
the creation of things like the healing
church the choir and the school of
mensis well the hunter's nightmare was
created in between these two events so
it was before the creation of the
healing church meaning the beast curse
had still yet to take form as lawrence
was still testing the blood's effects so
this realm is years old at this point
possibly the oldest realm we could visit
in game but this realm was created as a
curse against the college and the
hunters for what they did during the
early stages of experimentation and
research at the college master willem
would receive a word of a washed up
great one at a nearby fishing village
this great one was known as coss the
same one mikalash refers to during his
boss fight
as she once did for the vacuous rome
grant has eyes grant us eyes
it seems that rom ascended to the spider
form thanks to cost but given the word
vacuous is just another way to say lack
of intelligence it's probably out of
punishment for what occurred at the
village master willem upon hearing this
news immediately sent scholars and
hunters to investigate and the reports
were true a great one did exist within
the village but even though they were
turned into fish they revered kos and
saw her as a god in an attempt to
investigate this being's power further
the hunters and scholars brutally
destroyed cossa's body and even did the
same to some of the villagers it's
reported that they carved large gaping
holes in the skulls of the villagers and
also violated cossa's corpse by possibly
dissecting her skin and organs picasa is
a great one and even though a great
one's body may die its mind can continue
to live on because she was still alive
in a roundabout way she was able to put
a curse on all the scholars and hunters
all hunters and on occasion random
people as well will be cast into the
nightmare for eternity engaging in
endless hunting forever this is the fate
for all hunters as after enough time the
bloodlust will consume them so it's
inevitable that they end up here we can
enter the hunter's nightmare and put a
stop to it by eliminating costs however
her child will appear upon arriving at
the beach and fight us it's only after
defeating the orphan of cost that we can
slay the black spirit residing in costs
which destroys the nightmare but we have
quite a few ways to go before getting
there as we have four bosses to get
through first one thing you'll notice
about the old hunters dlc is that the
setting is identical to the cathedral
ward minus the massive chunks of debris
everywhere the reason why the cathedral
ward is here is that i believe the
hunter's nightmare is pulling in all the
locations of tragedy the fishing village
is here which is where the massacre took
place and the cathedral ward was the
base of operations for the church who
unleashed the beast curse upon yharnam
so it got pulled in here too some have
theorized that the debris everywhere is
the lack of knowledge the brain has when
dreaming if you think of a memory from
yesterday it's a lot more vivid than one
from a few years ago over time you'll
forget small parts of that memory until
it becomes impossible to remember
someone made a really great analogy and
it's at this area is like the cathedral
ward except the person assigned to
making the buildings didn't have the
blueprints it's impossible to remember
every single detail in the cathedral
ward which is why parts of it seem to be
missing i really like how this
environment ties into the real world
examples of how dreams and memories work
within our brains the first boss we find
in the nightmare is this fiery cleric
beast who we can't fight just yet so by
passing him and going the other way we
can make it to ludwig the accursed just
based on his appearance it's clear that
ludwig has been here for quite some time
ludwig was actually the first hunter of
the healing church workshop this is
different compared to gearman who was
the actual first ever hunter once lauren
split from the college they needed to
enlist the help of the hunters which led
to the creation of the hunter's workshop
which was of course run by german
however the arnomites grew wary of the
church and the workshop and believed
that the church had something to do with
the beast so lauren shut down the
workshop due to gearman and the other
hunter's failure to quell the threat
lawrence then created the new healing
church workshop and enlisted different
hunters to help him this failure also
ties into gearman quite a bit when
discussing the ending but we'll get to
that later ludwig was one of the early
hunters of the healing church workshop
and because he was one of those early
hunters over time he succumbed to the
blood and due to the curse being created
by cost was forced to live here for
eternity this is the same reason this
fiery cleric beast is here as this is
lawrence the same lawrence who created
the healing church and the one who
believed blood administration was the
key to ascension is now eternally stuck
in the hunter's nightmare i really like
the idea of making him a cleric beast as
he was obviously a high-ranking member
in the church just like the vicars and
clerics so it makes sense why their
appearances would be similar to even
activate this fight we need to find
lawrence's skull in the nightmare which
is way closer than you think is we can
use this lift and by letting it go up we
can find it underneath the original lift
his skull reads a symbol of lawrence's
past and what he failed to protect he's
destined to seek his skull but even if
he found it it would never restore his
memories so lawrence the leader of the
church has now become nothing but a
mindless beast the very thing he
unleashed upon the people of yharnam
which i find to be quite an ironic fate
the next area we visit is the research
hall and this location was where many
patients of yharnam were being
experimented on with the same purpose of
ascending this is backed up by the
palest skin similar to those who are
considered kin and at the top of this
building is a garden with the living
failures these flowers in the garden
were similar to the flowers in the
celestial emissary arena so it's
possible that these patients were being
used to create celestial emissaries but
the majority of them failed and even the
ones that did succeed the first step
couldn't become emissaries which is why
they're called the living failures but
what's odd though is that throughout
this area we hear people call out to a
lady maria who conveniently is our last
boss lady maria was one of the hunters
present for the massacre at the fishing
village she regretted her actions deeply
and thus decided to dedicate her time to
watching over the patients and taking
care of them we know this as her recuyo
the weapon she commonly uses can be
found in game at the bottom of a well
implying that throwing away this blade
was not only her trying to forget this
horrific event but also her giving up
her hunter status which led to her being
the permanent caretaker of the research
hall it's unclear how long she did this
for but she would eventually kill
herself over this guilt evident by the
bloodstain on her clothes implying that
she slit her throat once again due to
the curse she would then be sent to the
hunter's nightmare for eternity we also
discovered that lady maria is related to
queen annelise the same one at castle
cainhurst i don't think there's any more
development into this discovery but i
still think it is nice to know lady
maria is the one hiding the secret of
the hunter's nightmare and by killing
her we can walk through the fishing
village and uncover the real truth this
would then lead us to costs and if you
manage to kill her then you can end the
hunter's nightmare permanently allowing
everyone inside to finally achieve peace
the dlc for bloodborne was just like its
weapons there was a clear attention to
its quality rather than its quantity the
old hunters is not a long dlc and took
no longer than four hours to complete
but each of those four hours was not
only filled with engaging gameplay but
also important pieces of lore that fill
in some holes in the game's narrative
it's a fantastic dlc and a necessity if
you plan on playing this game returning
to yharnam we can now go back to the
nightmare of menses to defeat mergo
mergo might have one of the most
important roles in this game's story the
school of mensis obtained an umbilical
cord from a great one and used this to
communicate with mergo but things went
wrong and resulted in the stillbirth of
their brains which is why they're all
dead it's unclear why mikalash is the
only one alive but maybe it's because he
was the one who used the chord and thus
is alive in the nightmare realm but dead
in the real world but once again we're
entering that questionable territory the
reason we know this is because an
umbilical cord drops after killing mergo
these umbilical cords are key to the
game's secret ending after killing
myrgo's wet nurse the game pauses for a
moment and all we hear is a baby crying
after the crying is done we finally get
the nightmare slain title to appear this
implies that it wasn't the wet nurse who
was the objective but rather murgo
himself also something interesting is
that queen yharnam is outside the boss
arena and upon killing myrgo she bows
and disappears this may tie into what we
discuss with ram on how she is dead but
alive in the lake it's possible that she
thanks us for finally ending murgo and
subsequently her misery as they were
stuck in these realms despite assumingly
being dead already just like the old
hunters it's possible that we were
finally able to give the mother and
child the peace they needed to move on
regardless with mergo dead we returned
to the hunter's dream and it's on fire
talking with the doll she motions us
towards the gray tree where gearman is
located here is where we can get into
the endings of bloodborne and there is
three of them to discuss starting with
the first one this sees us accepting
gearman's proposal when we talk to
gearman he claims to offer us a way out
of the hunter's dream he's going to kill
us which will allow us to be free of the
hunt and the dream altogether should we
accept he decapitates us and we awaken a
more peaceful version of yharnam
afterward we can see the doll praying at
our grave and hoping that we find worth
in the waking world earlier we talked
about how yharnam was the waking world
and how these nightmare realms were the
dreamlands at least according to hp
lovecraft well this changes things as
this implies that the yharnam we explore
is just another realm and the real
yharnam is the one at the end of the
game as the doll calls it the waking
world there's always been one thing
that's bothered me about this game and
it's the dream itself this is the one
base of operations across the souls game
where nobody appears in the base we only
have the doll in gearman no one else
comes into this dream but we can tell
from the graves that others have come
before us but it seems that not every
hunter has been to the dream the only
hunters that have been confirmed to be
in the dream are de jura and eileen due
to some of their dialogue it's possible
that the hunter's dream is used by one
hunter at a time in order to stop the
hunt given how many graves there are and
that we see the doll prey near ours
after the first ending we can assume
that these other hunters were possibly a
part of the dream but were killed by
gearman and given his mercy in the case
of eileen and de jura maybe they're
already dead remember how we talked
about rom being dead and alive at the
same time maybe by accepting gearman's
mercy we become like eileen and dejira
we're still hunters that are still
partaking in the hunt but with little to
no memory of the hunter's dream and are
able to finally be free of its
never-ending curse remember the only
reason we're here in the dream is the
messengers and from playing the game we
can assume that no one really knows what
these are i believe it's tied to the
great one we'll see in just a bit so
maybe this yharnam really is the same
yharnam as before but we're just unaware
of the real story ignorance is bliss
after all the second ending is activated
upon refusing his offer german doesn't
take no for an answer and battles us if
we defeat german we finally get to see
the real boss of bloodborne the real
mystery of bloodborne this is the pale
blood we've been seeking and it's called
the moon presence if you've been
connecting some of the dots earlier i
said that each realm has a host like
myrgo and coss well this is the host of
the hunter's dream this moon presence is
related to the umbilical cords it's
known that these umbilical cords are
sort of communication devices used by
humans to talk to the great ones it's
unclear how this happened or even if
this happened but it's assumed that the
umbilical cord came from costs and was
split into three pieces willem took the
first piece lawrence and the church got
the second and mikelash in the school
got the third well during the events of
the healing church lawrence worked with
german to contain the threat of the
beasts for multiple different armor sets
and items we can piece together that
gearman had a deep love for maria but it
seemed like maria just respected him as
a teacher and a friend german never
really managed to confess his love to
her and even if he somehow managed later
to muster up the courage to do so it
wouldn't have mattered anyway because
maria took her own life in a desperate
attempt to keep her alive demon created
the doll that's why we see a doll in the
original hunter's workshop in yharnam
within the workshop is a small hair
piece that has a line in the description
that reads its color would stand most
brilliantly against a head of grayish
hair gray is the same color as maria's
hair which is also the same color as the
doll's hair and when giving this to the
doll she cries
what
what is this
i
i
can't remember
not a thing only i feel
a yearning something i never felt before
what's happening to me
tell me hunter
could this be joy
to add even more to this discovery when
we kill maria and return to the hunter's
dream and talk to the doll she says that
she feels liberated as if the great
shackles have been lifted off her
implying that she was made to be a
replacement for maria around this time
the church was failing the hunters were
failing and gearman had no motivation to
keep going having just lost the one he
loved so lawrence pitched an idea and
german would agree they would use their
third of the umbilical cord and ask a
great one for help this chord which is
the one we find in the hunters workshop
reads the third umbilical cord
precipitated the encounter with the pale
moon which beckoned the hunters and
conceived the hunter's dream the pale
moon also known as the moon presence is
the host of the hunter's dream it's
unclear what the rules of the contract
were but it's assumed that lawrence and
giermann probably wanted a way to defeat
the scourge beasts but contracts go both
ways the moon presence would keep german
in the hunter's dream with the intention
of training the hunters and continuing
the hunt it's been debated since the
release of the game what the actual
motivation of the moon presence is this
has been the biggest discussion amongst
the community and it's never gotten
anywhere going back to hp lovecraft it's
very clear that the great ones are the
same ones from his stories the issue
here is that the great ones were created
to be incomprehensible in every way
meaning not only can we not even begin
to understand what it even looks like
but not even what it wants despite some
of the beings having the same title the
great ones each have different
motivations and reasons for doing what
it does meaning its actions aren't like
those of the college where they wanted
all of humanity to ascend the great ones
seem to act purely out of self-interest
but as we know from the umbilical cords
all great ones lose their children and
yearn for a surrogate maybe the moon
presence just wants a child this relates
to ending two where we refuse gearman's
offer and then meet the moon presence
but it takes us in and replaces gearman
with us we are now the new helper of
hunters within the dream maybe it wants
a child but in a different way not an
infant like mergo but a grown one to
watch over which would be us maybe it
wants to keep the beast scourge going so
that more hunters will arrive at the
hunter's dream thus giving the place
purpose to exist and allowing the moon
presence to watch over the fight and
watch over us remember the moon presence
only arrives once we defeat german so
it's detected that something has
happened which is why it meets with us
it then realizes our power and seizes
the opportunity to have a new helper in
the dream many of the npcs say that the
night of the hunt is unending and that
it's going on longer than usual maybe
this is to be seen as quite literal that
the hunt will last forever as long as
the moon presence exists while there has
been a lot of speculation on this one
thing we can confirm though is that this
dream is not actually a dream as gearman
has some unique dialogue that you may
hear and it's quite disturbing
lawrence
master willem
somebody
help me
unshackle me please
anybody
i've had enough of this dream
the night blocks all sight
oh
somebody
please
for my interpretation of this this
either means that gearman realized he'll
be stuck here forever since lawrence and
willem are not in any state to come free
him from the dream or that he was
brought here against his will either way
we need to stop the moon presence and
thankfully there is a way should the
player consume the three umbilical cords
that being the one from mergo the one
from the old hunter's workshop and then
the last one from either ariana or
yosefka they can trigger the secret
ending instead of being enthralled by
its presence and becoming the new
gearman we resist its power the moon
presence will then see us as a threat
and attempt to get rid of us if we win
we become an infant great one and do
exactly what everyone has been trying to
do for years we finally did it we
discovered the true path to ascension
and with this profound knowledge in mind
we can now launch humanity into its next
childhood as i said the motivation for
the moon presence is unknown and will
likely never be known so it's up to our
interpretation but after this though we
officially come to the end of the story
of bloodborne and what a ride this has
been bloodborne might have one of the
best stories i've ever had the pleasure
of uncovering despite some of the
writing shortcomings mainly the lacking
of the explanation towards the moon
presence in the nightmare realms i still
consider this one of the best narratives
of all time i believe that not
everything needs to be mentioned in a
story for it to be considered good or
complete holes can be left with the
intention of having the player fill them
and this is one of my favorite parts of
the story being able to take a story
from any medium whether it's books or
games and being able to add my own
ending or my own thoughts to its canon
story it allows me to take everything
i've come to know about this game's
world its setting its characters and its
main plot and be able to make the story
my own in a way that makes sense to me
bloodborne is not only one of the best
games of all time it might also have one
of the best stories of all time and
while it does take lots of effort to
actually understand the story i think
that fits really well with the soul's
theme a genre of games that have been
known to be difficult and more than just
gameplay but of course by making it to
this part of the video you've more than
likely already had a lot of the stories
spoiled for you even so though i do
encourage you to pick up the game if you
can you will not regret it
but just as the story of bloodborne has
come to an end so too has this video
thank you all for watching today and i
really hope you enjoyed this took lots
of effort to make but i think after some
hours of research and brainstorming i
was able to piece it all together it's
quite easy to get tunnel vision when
making a video like this as you try to
focus on the bigger picture but end up
forgetting a small key detail along the
way so for whatever reason something i
said was incorrect do let me know in the
comments down below with that like the
video if you enjoy and subscribe if
you're new and thank you to my returning
viewers for coming back to another video
as always take care everyone
and goodbye
[Music]
you